the show is set in the year 1962 in a
parallel universe the axis power
comprising nazi germans and the imperial
japanese won world war ii and are now
the rulers of the entire world in this
universe the u.s president-elect
franklin d was assassinated amidst the
war and the bombing of hiroshima and
nagasaki never happened instead the
germans dropped an atomic bomb on
washington dc and weakened the allied
countries in the current world the
germans rule over all of europe and
africa and the empire of japan controls
all of asia however the point of power
is set in the former us which has since
been divided into two parts western
north america ruled by the japanese and
eastern and midwestern north america is
controlled by the greater nazi reich
also called the gnr the american flag
has a swastika instead of stars
indicating its complete surrender to the
nazis although the two empires won the
war hand-in-hand there has been a cold
war type relationship between them ever
since it is said that after the death of
the current fuhrer hitler his next in
command will take over all the japanese
states and declare themselves the rulers
of the world in both empires americans
are subjected to racism and have fewer
rights than germans and japanese in
their respective states the police are
allowed to kill any american if they
find them suspicious without having to
answer to anyone there is a neutral zone
between two former american states that
encompasses the rocky mountains it
serves as a neutral zone where no rules
of either empire work it is also a
hiding zone for the resistance group
that is constantly protesting for their
rights and freedom then we are
introduced to joe blake who lives in
nazi occupied new york tired of being a
slave to the nazis he is looking to
become a part of a resistance group from
various sources he has finally
discovered the address of the new york
leader of the group as he travels to the
said place we see times square
billboards filled with nazi propaganda
and advertisements about the fuhrer the
headquarters turns out to be a shipping
company and the leader is a manager
named don joe tells him that he is a
rebel but don laughs in his face joe has
gotten their address which means he is
already qualified to be their ally but
according to don someone like him will
blurt out all their secrets to the
police if caught joe tells the manager
that his will to fight is not that weak
and don ultimately gives him a chance as
his first task he is asked to drive a
truck filled with coffee machines to
cannon city colorado which is a neutral
zone joe inquires what else the truck
contains but he is asked to do as told
without asking any questions right
before he leaves the place is raided by
the nazis joe manages to drive away
while don is caught and arrested it
turns out that the third highest nazi
rank officer
smith initiated the raid he used to be a
us army captain before he joined hands
with the nazis and is now loyal to them
when told about joe and the truck the
obergluppenfielder orders his people to
catch the truck at any cost then we are
taken to san francisco a japan ruled
city in the west juliana is an aikido
expert and a happy american living under
japanese control one day after practice
she is approached by her friend named
dhoni who has a crush on her he asks her
out on a coffee date but juliana reveals
that she already has a boyfriend named
frank later that day she meets her
sister trudy who has been m.i.a for the
past week trudy is happy about something
and claims that her life is about to
change for the better then we see
juliana meet frank who is great at art
however since the japanese are not a big
fan of modern art he has taken a job as
a mechanic in a factory as they chat we
find out that frank is jewish and is
always living in fear of the nazis this
is why juliana doesn't want to have his
children because they will also be
subjected to fear every day of their
lives after the date juliana is
returning home when suddenly trudy stops
her she frantically hands her a film and
claims that it is the only way to
freedom with that being said she runs
away and is killed by the police a few
minutes later julianna witnesses this
and runs into her apartment before
playing the content of the film which is
named the grasshopper lies heavy it
shows a world where the nazis were
defeated and how world politics played
out after that juliana is in shock as
the video gives her a taste of freedom
and makes her want to fight had she been
shown an episode of keeping up with the
kardashians instead she may have opted
to leave things the way they are after
that we find out that the film is a
product distributed by someone named the
man in the high castle not even the high
high-ranking officials know who he is or
what he wants but he seems to be an ally
to the resistance group who has access
to the things that normal people don't
the government has put a ban on these
films but they continue being
distributed secretly frank arrives home
and freaks out upon finding out that
juliana has a film he wants to hand it
over to the police first thing in the
morning so they won't be in trouble the
next morning juliana finds a ticket to
canon city with an address and a time it
is clear that her sister had to bring
the film to that place but now it is her
responsibility when frank isn't around
she runs away with the film to the bus
station she also hides the film under
another one to cover up the story even
if she is caught in the following scene
we are taken to the german embassy in
the japan-ruled empire a high-ranking
nazi commander hugo meets the japanese
trade minister tagomi who has come to
inform them about the arrival of the
japanese prince and princess even the
german embassy must be decorated
according to their taste which doesn't
satisfy the germans still they agree to
do it to avoid unwanted tension
somewhere else don has been tied to the
ceiling and tortured the open group
infurer and his right hand man eric
whose name is significantly easier to
pronounce come to meet him but don
remains unbothered by their presence and
continues his silence meanwhile joe's
truck stops on the way because of a flat
tire as a kind man helps him replace it
joe notices ashes in the air it turns
out that somewhere nearby the germans
are burning mentally and physically
disabled people because they don't want
to waste their resources on them guess
you can't teach an old genocidal
psychotic call to new tricks after that
joe continues the journey until he
reaches a police check post in a moment
of heat he brings out a film from under
the truck and hides it somewhere else
the police do not find it and set him
free like juliana joe's job is also to
supply the film to someone in canon city
juliana meets a man named randall who is
supposed to meet her sister he is also a
resistance member and thinks that
juliana is not suitable for the job they
get into an argument about who gets to
take the film to canon city and decide
that juliana should do it because the
person receiving the film thinks he is
meeting a woman on her way to the city
juliana's bag is stolen by another woman
who runs away with all her money and the
fake film juliana continues the journey
without money adamant about doing her
sister's job first at frank's work he
and a co-worker named ed are talking
about politics soon he and randall who
juliana was talking to earlier are
arrested for hiding the film from the
police juliana reaches the hotel in
canon city and waits for the person she
is supposed to meet while she is at it
she meets joe who pays for her meal
because her wallet was stolen they chat
for a while and make friends with each
other then we see joe making a call to
the obergruppenfuhrer revealing that he
is a spy working for the nazis and the
one responsible for dawn's arrest back
in san francisco frank and randall are
imprisoned and tortured officer keto
threatens to kill frank's entire family
if he doesn't reveal juliana's location
by tomorrow later frank and randall are
left alone and the latter asks frank not
to tell anyone about juliana because
what she is doing is greater than
frank's family ultimately frank's sister
laura and her two children are brought
to the police station and asked to wait
in a room keto tells frank that they are
about to poison all three of them in
half an hour and gives him time to think
it over then in canon juliana and joe's
friendship deepens but joe has started
to suspect that she is a rebel juliana
then starts working as a waitress in the
diner she meets a customer named alan
who is reading a bible when juliana
shows interest in it he gives her the
name of a store where she can get the
book she goes to the store while being
watched by joe at the same time in new
york the obergruppenfield and his
assistant eric are attacked by a group
of rebels obergruppenfuhrer manages to
kill all of them and arrest a man named
doug to interrogate him elsewhere
juliana meets allen again and claims
that she has something important to tell
him they decide to meet on a bridge at
night before leaving for the meeting
juliana gives joe a letter and asks him
to post it to her mother if she doesn't
return joe calls the ober group in
future asking him to find out about a
man named alan who he suspects of being
a rebel following the call he reads the
letter where juliana has told her mother
about the wonderful world that the film
has shown her unable to control himself
joe also watches the film that he
possesses on seeing an alternate reality
his heart is filled with the will to
fight back soon he is informed that alan
is not a rebel but a nazi spy like
himself knowing that juliana's life is
in danger joe brings out his gun and
goes to the bridge back in san francisco
randall is taken away to be executed
keto asks frank to reveal juliana's
location for the last time but he keeps
quiet as a result the poisonous gas is
released in the room that frank's sister
laura and her children are in frank is
also taken to be executed alongside
randall minutes before his execution
keto finds the woman who stole from
juliana on the bus upon discovering the
fake film they assume that juliana and
frank are innocent frank is saved
seconds before his death but his family
dies because of keto's mistake then on
the bridge allen tries to kill juliana
but is interrupted by joe's arrival
juliana pushes him off the bridge and
kills him right after she breaks down
crying while joe holds her in his arms
they return to the hotel where joe helps
julianna relax despite the guilt of
killing a person weighing her down she
manages to keep her cool she inquires if
joe read the letter she left for her
mother and he replies with a yes juliana
doesn't mind because she trusts him and
thinks that he did it because he was
worried for her the two have to check
out the hotel as soon as possible
because a dead nazi agent means that
more are going to come looking for them
they settle on checking out at different
times to avoid being suspected back in
san francisco frank returns to his
apartment and goes to sleep what he has
been through in the last 24 hours has
weakened him to his core ed comes to
meet his friend and is glad to see him
alive but frank doesn't show any
interest in his concerns frank also
receives an official letter from the
japanese police about a funeral being
held for laura and her dead children he
then goes to the police station and
identifies the dead bodies as his family
by the time he is done frank's sorrow
has turned into rage he wants to avenge
the japanese for killing his innocent
family he gets a perfect opportunity to
do so when the japanese crowned prince
and princess arrive in san francisco
upon returning home frank gets a call
from juliana but ends it abruptly he
blames her for the deaths and doesn't
want to associate with her until his
anger calms down somewhere else the
obergruppen feuder gets a call from joe
and inquires if he has found more rebels
in the diner referring to juliana
however joe lies claiming that he
doesn't suspect anyone but he wants to
wait for a week to confirm the
obergruppenfuhrer orders otherwise
because the rebels should have come by
now and their absence only means that
they caught on to the nazi plan joe
agrees and goes to a gas station to
prepare for the trip back home then we
are introduced to another nazi soldier
marshall he is known for killing
hundreds of rebels around the neutral
zone and is an absolute nazi propaganda
follower he suspects joe and asks for
his card which causes the two of them to
get into an argument after confirming
joe's identity the man shows alan's
picture to a bystander
he is the agent sent to investigate
allen's disappearance joe quickly meets
juliana at the diner and tells her about
his eventful meeting with another nazi
spy they do not have more time to beat
around the bush and need to flee as soon
as possible at first they search the dam
for alan's body and dispose of it so
marshall won't find it in the meantime
marshall goes to the bookstore that alan
often used to visit the owner carl
claims that he knows nothing until
marshall brings out a card with his true
identity
it turns out that carl is a rebel
refugee from ohio to save his life the
man tells marshall about a girl who came
to buy the bible under alan's suggestion
despite getting the information he
wanted marshall doesn't spare carl and
ends his life
not just that but he makes a statement
by hanging his dead body in front of
everyone and ordering them to let it rot
after that he continues his search and
ends up outside the diner that juliana
works in a stranger claims that he knows
where allen is but asks for money in
turn for the information marshall makes
him spill everything he knows and leaves
for the bridge having found out that was
the last place alan was spotted back in
san francisco the crown prince and
princess are taking a stroll down a park
with many councilmen after the event the
prince privately tells the princess
about his concerns regarding the nazi's
growing technologies they have surpassed
japan in many ways and have to be
stopped before another world war breaks
out after hitler's death in the next
scene we see trade minister tagomi
talking to a nazi scientist named wegner
they are here to make a very important
deal that might have a huge impact on
world history wegner knows the recipe
for an atom bomb which nazis possess but
japan lacks he is willing to share the
recipe with the japanese science
minister so the country can be ready in
case they are attacked tagomi asks
wegner to hand the recipe to the
japanese science minister on the day of
the crown prince's speech because it is
when everyone will be distracted the
crowned prince and princess go to meet
the nazi ambassador to discuss the
speech the prince is about to deliver to
a crowd of san francisco residents the
ambassador suggests they cancel the
speech as it might not be entirely safe
but the monarch trusts keto's team to
ensure complete safety no one would dare
to lay a finger on him after all as he
is the prince of the entire japanese
empire back in canon city joe and
juliana are disposing of allen's car
when they find a map inside a marked
place intrigues their interest and they
decide to travel to see what it is at
the same time marshall reaches the
bridge and finds a drawing of juliana
that she had dropped when she was here
with alan last night the mistake might
cost her her life but she is busy
exploring the mapped place with joe it
turns out to be a camp where the
revolutionaries are locked and tortured
the horrifying sight of a chained dead
woman shakes them both alongside the
corpse is a list of revolutionaries who
have been killed or are yet to be
captured trudy's name is also there but
what shocks them the most is the name of
the diner's owner lemuel this means that
the person juliana has been working with
until now is also a rebel marshall is in
the diner with lemuel asking him if he
has seen juliana around the neighborhood
the owner reveals that she used to work
for him but lies about her disappearing
a few days ago meanwhile frank is still
not in the right state of mind he
continuously tries to gain more
information about the japanese prince by
listening to the radio non-stop then we
see him making a gun for himself because
he works in a factory that manufactures
its parts ed inquires what he needs it
for but frank doesn't reply later that
day ed catches frank practicing shooting
in his apartment he carefully inquires
if frank is planning to assassinate the
crowned prince but again does not get a
reply ed tells frank to think of every
step he takes because he won't be
forgiven by the police if he does
something irrational in the next scene
joe and juliana are on the drive back to
the diner before marshall stops them
juliana makes a run for her life and
hides inside an abandoned home all while
being followed by him after a few
minutes long search they come face to
face and marshall is seconds away from
blowing her head off with his shotgun
but right then joe comes to her aid and
knocks the nazi out before running away
with juliana they hide inside a house
nearby tricking marshall into assuming
that they ran away only after he drives
away in his car do they sigh with relief
to seek refuge they go to lemule's home
he listens to their story before asking
for the film she got from trudy however
juliana insists that she will only hand
over the film to the man in the high
castle because she doesn't trust anyone
else lemuel promises to bring them to
the main man the following morning joe
then surprises us by telling all the
information to the open group and fyodor
smith but he doesn't tell him about the
part where he helped juliana morning
comes and lemuel brings joe and juliana
on a hike in the woods however halfway
in they are surrounded by a group of
revolutionaries who recognize joe as a
spy he proves his innocence by showing
them the film that he wouldn't have
brought if he was a spy moreover juliana
also takes his side since he has helped
her against the nazis time and again
lemuel apologizes for the misinformation
and asks them to go to a place on the
other side of the hill to stay away from
marshall who is desperately looking for
them elsewhere wegner is preparing
microfilm with information about how to
manufacture an atom bomb he is to hand
this film to the japanese science
minister during the speech that is about
to take place shortly hours before the
speech frank buys a bunch of bullets
under the name of a japanese person
living in tibet the owner of the shop
helps him when offered an absurd amount
of money ed finds the loaded gun and
tries to stop frank from doing anything
stupid in the ensuing struggle frank is
shot in the shoulder but he manages to
lock ed inside a room and make his way
to the speech juliana is trying to steal
a car for their escape but marshall
catches her in the act she drives away
in a hurry causing her to get into an
accident that burns her alive marshall
inspects her burning corpse before
confirming that yep she's dead what he
doesn't know is that it was a plan set
by joe and juliana to get him off their
backs when everything calms down
julianna calls frank but ed picks up the
phone he tells her everything frank has
been up to prompting her to take the
immediate next bus to san francisco joe
watches her go in shock and feels
betrayed meanwhile in san francisco the
prince's speech finally starts wegner is
in the crowd about to hand over the
microfilm to the science minister
somewhere nearby is frank getting ready
to take his revenge as he pulls the gun
out slowly someone else shoots the
prince before him the episode ends as he
watches the injured prince in
astonishment to know what happens to
them next watch the second part in our
new channel series recapped